joining me now is molly hemingway
editor-in-chief at the federalist fox
news contributor and stephen miller
former senior advisor to president trump
founder of america first legal
molly um
let's start in reverse order of the
shiny objects that we discussed let's
start first with hillary clinton
emerging on the scene this week
kind of playing coy with 2024
but i think it sounded like
without a doubt to me hillary is back in
the game yeah she's not known for
subtlety so it didn't come off coy and
it's really a sign of desperation on
both the part of the democrat party but
also hillary clinton that they're trying
to you know get the gang back together
to have another round of things she was
a terrifically bad candidate in 2016 you
know for getting to visit the state of
wisconsin being so unlikable that
americans really could not envision you
know so many americans couldn't envision
voting for her but it really is a
testament to how dire the democrat
party's situation is right now that they
are that don't have a good bench and
they are looking for someone who at
least seemed more competent than joe
biden does
and the dnc chair um stephen
tried to spin the democrats
dire situation this way watch
we are seeing right now uh an energy and
an activism particularly amongst women
that we have not seen uh
since the the election of donald trump
and the martian
women's march we have to make sure that
we push back against these republican
efforts to take away american rights
stephen
the cook political report today
came out with an analysis of eight new
races six of them
are now
pointing toward the republicans that's
in addition to the other 30 or 35 or so
i think they think maybe 25 seats
so far for the republicans as a pickup
um but i don't know what fantasyland
he's living in but
you know this this doesn't seem like
it's going in their direction
well they're right that they are
energizing women to run as fast and as
far as they can from the democratic
party and into the arms of republican
candidates i mean you saw history being
made when congresswoman flores won in
the 84 percent democrat latino
district and won convincingly in a
special election
the first mexican-born congresswoman in
the united states of america all the
democrats have to offer is this circus
show of conspiracy theories and witch
hunts on january 6. and now this new
immediately debunked james bond fantasy
and
opening
right about you know this crazy story
about trying to commandeer a vehicle
that was debunked within 30 minutes of
it being told and then of course they
have this single issue of late term
abortion on demand through the ninth
month so we're saying we want to create
more jobs we want to create more
opportunity we want to create safety we
want to secure the border we want to
lower inflation and all they're saying
is we've got january 6 and abortion
clinics that's it
and molly to steven's last point there
i want to move uh on to this disaster on
the hill today this cassidy hutchison
wasn't the only one caught lying
if you had any question about whether
the president knew these people were
armed
or that they were dangerous i think it
it's pretty clear from that testimony
today
he knew what a threat they posed and yet
he was insistent
on marching to the capital the point of
potentially getting an altercation
without his own secret service about it
molly reaction to that i mean from your
old pal if adam schiff is saying
something it's a pretty good indication
that it's not true
this committee has engaged in widespread
manipulation of evidence they're
refusing to provide the testimony of
people who dispute the narrative that
they're trying to construct
they are really running roughshod over
our american ideals of what should
happen when you accuse people of crimes
and whether there should be
an ability to make a defense or have a
cross-examination i mean those rights
are enshrined in the constitution and
our congressional committees are
supposed to honor that in the way that
they conduct their hearings that has not
been the case since day one and today
this was just absurd and i have to say
if you believed this absolutely
ludicrous story from this person even
before it was disputed by everyone on
the record you should not be involved in
politics in journalism you should really
think deeply about whether you're able
to really analyze information at the
level that you should yeah these are
so-called journalists steven
i've written in the beast a few times
and and i can't i couldn't remember
if you could even reach across can you
even reach that way to get i couldn't
remember but it seemed the whole no the
whole story seemed ridiculous but you
knew you knew cassidy hutchison what
kind of a you know i've met her a few
times but i didn't really have much
contact look at him
she's an extremely junior low-level aide
i don't think i ever had a conversation
with her that i can at least recall of
any of any substance or death but but to
molly's point this is a rorschach test
for your sanity if you heard this story
and you thought man i believe every word
of this i'm going to go online and say
something about it energetically
something is wrong with you something is
wrong with you if you're that gullible
especially after five years of the
hoaxes and the witch hunts and the
fabrications people keep falling for it
again and again and again and again at
what point do people just lose their
credibility and molly do you notice she
kept saying
something something to that effect
she kept couching everything she said a
lot of it was hearsay
obviously not admissible in any kind of
real a court um but she kept saying
something to that effect whether it was
about trump's reaction to pence and the
hanging chant or but i i found it all it
was like she was auditioning for a seat
of the view or the real staffers of
pennsylvania avenue or so it just seemed
like an audition tape that wasn't going
well for her god bless her i mean i i
don't know i don't know her well but it
just seemed bad well i mean when you
have people coming out and saying that
they did not in fact tell this
information that she claimed that she
had been told by them it is probably
wise of her to distance herself from her
own testimony but again this is really
the fault of the committee there is not
a single republican appointed member of
this committee they are not engaged in
any rights of minorities they are not
engaged in any
back and forth on evidence they are
lying and they've done it with really
high level witnesses and it has massive
implications because the department of
justice appears to just be following
their lead in what they're choosing to
prosecute and who they're choosing to
target this is a really serious attack
on the country and on our norms and it's
i know a lot of people on the right are
checking out because it is so absurd but
what they're doing is very damaging and
very good amen now i'm glad you said
that stephen they're trying to make her
out to be like alexander vinman right
like she's she's the new vinman for for
the for the this the latest chapter and
the attacks on uh on him well if she
tries to start a war in europe maybe she
will be alexandria
but look the bottom line here is that
these secret service agents that we're
seeing according to news reports that
are vociferously rebutting this these
are decades-long distinguished career
nonpartisan law enforcement officers it
doesn't get more credible than that when
it comes to rebutting a fantastical
fairy tale aside from the fact that it
looks like she wanted to go down to
mar-a-lago and work down there and i
guess she was next i mean she was on the
manifest at one point one of the
staffers told me
molly steven great to see you both hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else